et tout autre chose à présent direction
la côte d'azur l'une de nos équipes a
promené sa caméra dans les coulisses
d'un palace de saint-jean-cap-ferrat
suite jardin piscine tout doit être
parfait pour des clients fortunés
exigeants et parfois capricieux le luxe
côté coulisses c'est un reportage de
didier ben régnant et de georges minois
le grand hôtel du cap ferrat
l'un des plus luxueux de la côte d'azur
la saison estivale bat son plein et
l'hôtel affiche complet
53 chambres n'a suite beaucoup de
travail pour le personnel au deuxième
étage c'est l'effervescence dans
quelques heures un magna russes arrivent
par avion privé
il vient fêter son anniversaire mais il
ya un imprévu
sa chambre est occupé par un autre
client fortuné la décision délicate est
prise lors du briefing du directeur et
messieurs bonjour il faut déloger l'un
des deux il peut essayer de refuser mais
nous avons comment dirais-je certains
arguments et parfois avec une bouteille
de champagne ce genre de choses peuvent
trouver très facilement une solution au
coeur de l'hôtel un parc naturel de 7
hectares au milieu de la pinède
le summum du luxe ce funiculaire pour
rejoindre la piscine les employés
s'activent avant l'arrivée des premiers
baigneurs
arnaud travail ici chaque été depuis
quinze ans et il a un truc pour détendre
les clients multi blague
en français en anglais et en japonais
même en russe ou en moto et en russe est
plus biette neuf dans l'eau via mais en
fait non j'ai pas de blague ruisseau
faut que je bosse une bague russe retour
à l'hôtel
le client de la 208 a accepté de quitter
la chambre mais les employés doivent
encore tout débarrasser et il faut faire
vite
l'heure tourne et rien n'est encore prêt
pour l'anniversaire du vacancier russe
va être vite refaite par la femme de
chambre
elle termine celle qu'elle fait
maintenant elle vient pour faire le
départ ici il n'est rien on prépare les
ballons on prépare tout une demi-heure
de préparation
finalement tout sera prêt à temps en
arrivant le richissime russe découvrir à
sa suite décorées avec sur la table du
champagne et des macarons une dizaine de
femmes de chambres auront été mobilisés
pour un seul client
hier il ya les services et à la propreté
et à l'efficacité il faut qu'elle soit
vraiment à l'écouté de la clientèle et
de sa gouvernance qui vont donner les
directives pour que la journée de vol
bien
au total près de 170 personnes
travaillent ici pour satisfaire les
moindres désirs d'une cinquantaine de
vacanciers fortunés qui séjournent à
l'hôtel prêt à débourser minimum 800
euros pour une nuit passée dans ce
palace